MATT FEIGAL: I'd like to
take a quick temperature
check of the audience.
Who is running
what you would call
microservices in production
today at your company?
A lot of people.
OK, good.
Who is running more
than 60 of them
in parallel at
your company today?
OK, fewer.
There are some challenges
still to overcome
in getting up this road.
And a lot of you didn't
even raise your hand
because you're not running
them in production.
Pay attention, then, because
as you make this journey,
you're going to need this
information pretty soon.
The structure of
our talk today--
first, I'm going to
talk about this journey
to cloud native microservices,
and why it's a great place
to make them resilient and
make your developers focusing
on the pieces you want them to.
Jean from Blendle will talk
about his experience of this,
and his team's experience going
through exactly this story
at Blendle.
And then in the second
half, after Jean,
I will go into a bit
more technical details
about microservices
on Kubernetes.
[PHONE RINGING]
I don't think that's my phone.
OK, good.
We are a little behind schedule,
so we will speed up, accelerate
through some pieces a bit.
If we skip over some stuff
that you really wish you knew,
that you think is the most
important part, sorry.
We will be hanging out here
at the end of the stage.
Please come up and just ask
us, hey, what about that?
You skipped over that too
fast, I didn't understand.
We'd like to share.
So from a background, I
am a software developer
by background.
I spent a lot of years doing it.
I love it!
But the challenges can be hard.
And these days, it's not
really getting any easier
to be a software developer.
So in the old days--
the good old days, we
like to imagine them--
this was all I had to
worry about, right?
I would write my code,
I would compile it.
I would ship it to the
users, they would install it.
They would call me with some
annoying support questions
sometimes, usually a PEBKAC
error or something like that.
And then we would
write a new version,
compile it, ship
it to them again.
That was it.
That was simple.
I could focus on this business
problem that my product owner--
we didn't call them
that back then--
that my business
needed to solve,
or my customer needed to solve,
that would make us more money.
And then things started to
get a little more complicated.
But they're still
pretty simple, right?
We had a client--
that's a Palm Pilot,
not an Android,
so you know how old I am.
We had a Java back-end
where we stuck everything--
the authentication, inventory
management rules, a logging
library.
It was probably just
one server back then.
Or one time, it was my laptop,
because we couldn't deploy it
into the server room.
So we stuck my laptop into the
data center with a note saying,
"Don't unplug this, please."
So it's not necessarily
the good old days.
There was a database
managed by our DBA.
She would really help us
out with tuning the index
and planning this stuff.
But we had to all work together.
And we thought a lot about
software architecture--
patterns, best
practices-- but it
was still three monoliths that
were tightly coupled together.
Which is actually-- we'd
still ship and compile them
on all big chunks,
but on a rollout,
we have to coordinate
with downtime.
And we really actually had
one scattered monolith,
which, we made lives a
lot harder for ourselves.
Fast forward many, many years.
A lot has happened.
The next stage in that journey
is this explosive growth
of the internet,
new technologies.
World Press Photos was
talking to you about the fact
that times are
changing, companies
need to move faster because
the environment's faster.
So we start decomposing
our scattered monoliths
into microservices that
we can test and deploy
individually and faster,
keep functionality alive.
That's microservices.
We build up automation
services for better deployments
to keep these systems alive.
And our modern
applications start
to look a little bit like this.
Oh!
That's not three-tier.
That's a whole bunch of stuff.
We've got it
separated across zones
so that if one whole zone
dies, it stays alive.
We keep serving to our users.
Ooh, but now that
they're separated,
we need to load balance
between those machines
and those machines, and we
need to have coordination
of state between them
so we have task queues--
and oh, wait, health checks
that need to be coordinated.
And wow, it just
got complicated.
Because what I want as a
developer to care about
is this-- this little
piece, this red piece.
My product owner
wants me to build it,
I need to build it to
make money for my business
or my customers.
I want to knock a new feature
out the door every week.
But in order to do that, I
have to understand all of this.
In order for my
application to live here,
I've got to understand
what's happening.
I can't just write my Java
code or write my Python code
and trust it's going to go well.
And not just me, and
not just my teams,
but each of the 20
other deployment
teams running the 60 other
microservices we have to have.
All have to have
the same picture,
use their head cycles
understanding this,
stay consistent
about how they do it.
Otherwise, you're in trouble.
And pieces of this
infrastructure
start creeping into my code.
How do I handle
backoff requests?
How do I configure-- how
do I find those services?
Stuff that I shouldn't have
to write into my code that
makes it harder to operate
my own code because
of this infrastructure.
My application shouldn't care
that it's running in this.
It should just run,
and the environment
should take care of it.
And this is without
even touching
on these many other
complicated parts of it that
start creeping into my code.
My team might be using a
completely different tooling
than that other team, because
they evaluated their problem,
and they said, you know what?
Go is the right
thing for us to use.
We need high-streaming
throughput.
Another team says,
you know what?
.NET is the right
thing for this.
My team says no, we love Python.
There's no good reason for
it, just religious reasons--
and that's happened sometimes.
But there's usually
a good reason.
So in the interest of time, I'm
going to skip all over these.
I think you all recognize these.
What I really want to
do is write some code
to solve a business problem
to make it fun for me,
because I like that.
I like knocking a new
feature out every week
to create a new business
opportunity, to make money
for my customers, or whatever.
So what happened?
It's not the writing of
the code that got hard.
That's still fun, knocking
out these problems every week.
Running that code in
production, keeping
it alive with the requirements
of the crazy modern times
is creating all sorts of
complexity for our teams.
So in the good old days,
we'd write our code,
we'd pass it to the
QA team for testing.
They'd send it back
to us five times.
We'd give it to the ops
teams, and we're done.
It's not my problem, they
take care of it-- woo!
In my company in my old days,
we were pretty friendly.
We knew each other.
We liked each other.
So we would refer to them
as those poor bastards who
had to handle the crap
we gave them, and had
a lot of out-of-memory
errors, and stuff like that.
And they would call
us those idiots
who keep sending us this stuff.
And we had a positive
relationship, right?
So we have silos
and inefficiencies.
It really boils down
to cost and slowness.
We all know what
I'm talking about.
Today, we've moved
ahead many years.
Nowadays, it's your problem.
It's your team's problem.
Remember, DevOps is
not a title, or it
shouldn't be just a title
of someone on your team.
It's a whole team culture.
So the QA is now the problem
of every person on the team.
You're responsible
for the code you ship,
that the deployment works.
If you're causing
out-of-memory errors,
someone's going to tell
your team about it,
and then they fix it.
This is the way it works.
But you just want to
focus on that application.
So you're going
to need a tooling
to make this not your problem,
or at least a solved problem.
What would this look like in an
ideal world for a development
team and an ops team, a company
trying to run all of this
together?
You want every one of
your developer teams
to write what they want
in a way that they can--
in the language they want and
deploy it in the same way.
Oh-- there will be more.
Don't worry.
You want that app
to just deploy.
You just want to say,
here's the application,
the structure I want.
Make it so, and it's going
to live in this environment.
I don't want to have
to worry about it.
And hopefully, you don't have to
deal with the physical machines
themselves, right?
It's just you need a place
for this application to run.
This environment is
going to give them
the space to run that you
don't have to stress out about.
So what would such
a solution look
like in the modern cloud world?
Well, we'd have
container packaging
for predictable
deployment, dynamic
scheduling to make sure that
our application found a place
to run, and recomputing
that when necessary.
And it's got to be
microservices oriented, right?
It's got to be
something that supports
this type of thing-- reusability
of code, fast feature
release, loose coupling.
So let's start the journey.
And wow, we're
really short on time.
Unless this clock's a little--
started before I got on stage.
We tried this running on VMs.
It didn't quite deliver.
We never quite got the
efficiency that we wanted.
automation we wanted.
It works, but it requires
a lot of extra work.
Just skipping ahead from that,
the modern developer world,
and the DevOps,
and the ops teams
are falling in love
with containers.
We abstract away the operating
system of the containers.
Your application only needs
to think about its interfaces
with other applications
in your environment.
It doesn't need
to think about all
these load-balancing things.
They give our development
teams a consistent way
to package our applications
and deliver them,
and dependencies so my
laptop doesn't end up
in the data center again.
It's a great solution to
many of these problems.
And if we only had one machine
that never failed and never ran
out of resources, we'd
put them all on it.
And life would be
good, and we'd be done.
But that's not the
real world, either.
So we've figured out dockers
are great, containers are great.
But now we have a new
set of challenges.
Computers-- everything
you solve-- oh, there's
a new challenge behind it.
So once we fall in
love with containers
we try to build a system with
50 services, microservices,
built out of 500 running
containers across 30 machines.
And we discover that there's
a new layer of complexity
how we do these things.
Luckily, Google has some
experience with this.
We've been running containers in
our data centers for 12 years.
So we start about 2
billion containers a week--
Gmail, Search, Maps.
Everything you touch at Google,
you're touching a container.
It's running on a container.
The point of that is
we have some experience
at understanding how
to structure containers
in production and
run them efficiently.
So about 2 and 1/2
or 3 years ago,
we launched this really
cool open source project
called Kubernetes.
We took the lessons
we'd learned,
we packaged them up into
an open-source community,
we gave it to the
Linux Foundation,
the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation.
Recruited community members
like crazy, tons of people
doing stuff on it.
And basically, we
built Kubernetes
to solve this problem.
We wanted to expose the
way we work to the world.
We wanted people to
be able to do this.
It's a great orchestrator for
your containers in production.
You can run it anywhere.
But when you run it at
Google, a lot of things
are automatically
handled for you.
Like the master, which
is your control point--
I don't have any architecture
diagrams about that.
It's managed by Google,
so you don't have
to worry about upgrades, nodes.
You tell the master the way you
want your application to look.
It gives you the
nodes to run on.
If you need more or less,
it takes care of that.
It decides where to
stick those applications.
It routes traffic to them so
outside users can find them,
and your internal
services can find them.
And it's responsible for
setting up and keeping it
that way as life goes
on, and things break,
and things change.
So I'm going to go
into technical details
in the second part.
But first, I'm going to
hand it over to Jean Mertz,
the CTO of Blendle.
His company has been on
this journey for a while,
and he's going to
share his information
about that experience of
moving into microservices,
from monolith to microservices,
and how Kubernetes helped them
with that.
So Jean, come on up!
Thanks for joining me.
JEAN MERTZ: Thanks, man.
MATT FEIGAL: I hand over.
JEAN MERTZ: Thank you.
Morning, everyone.
So I'm going to try to be as
enthusiastic as Matt was just
now.
But those are some tough shoes
to fill, so bear with me.
So just a quick question first.
Who have you have heard
of Blendle before?
Great, quite some hands.
For those of you who
didn't raise your hand,
let me just quickly
introduce you to our product.
So Blendle is an
online kiosk that
helps you find the journalism
and background stories that
are interesting to you.
We present you the best stories
you should read every morning
and deliver them to you via
email, via the native apps
that we have, et cetera.
There are no pay walls, no ads.
It is you and great journalism.
You either pay with a
few cents per article,
or last January we launched
Blendle Premium, in which you
pay a fixed fee
every month, and we
send you a selection
of articles that
are most interesting to you.
We also have a staff of
editors who make sure
that we try to burst your
filter bubble everyday again.
Once you click on an
article, you can read it.
And we are very proud
of the UI and UX
that we put a lot of time in.
So this is the interface
that you get when you read.
And you can see it's all
about you and the story.
It's presented in the way that
the author meant it to be read.
So there are no ads,
no annoying pop-ups.
And we have a huge selection
of newspapers and magazines
you can pick from.
You see "Bloomberg Business
Week," "Time" magazine.
We also have "New York Times,"
"Economist," "Mother Jones,"
"Wall Street Journal," "The New
Yorker," et cetera, et cetera.
So there's always something
interesting to you.
If you want to check out
more, go to Blendle.com
or download the app
in the App Store.
But let's talk about
why you're here.
Let's talk about
our technical stack.
So we have currently
got 32 employees--
actually, 32 engineers
working on our product.
We are a polyglot
development environment,
which means we use Ruby
for back-end stuff,
but we also use Python
for data scientists.
We use GoLine for where
we need performance,
and a lot of other languages.
And this is
something which we'll
get into where
containers really help.
We've also got native
apps and a website
which is built with React.
We started out with a monolith,
but which startup doesn't?
And we'll also get
into that, because it's
important to realize that
starting with a monolith
is key to understanding
how you're going
to implement microservices.
But in the past year, we've been
slowly but surely splitting off
microservices from
that monolith.
So let me give you some context.
There are some numbers
here about our production
applications.
The most interesting ones--
we are generating more than 50
million personalized bundles
every month.
And we're sending
more than 400,000
personalized newsletters
in under 10 minutes
to all of our customers.
And this is really key when
you look at microservices,
because depending on
the needs that you have
for your small part
of your application,
you might decide to build your
application in a specific way
or with a specific language.
If you need simplicity,
you use a language
that's easy to work with
and easy to understand.
If you need performance, you
use C++ or Go, or whatever.
So it's key to understand
your application
and when to use what.
So our journey brought us from
the monolith on bare metal
to microservices on a
container-based cloud
infrastructure.
And there's more to come in the
coming years, I'm sure of that.
There is a big
community around it,
as we saw in the Keynote area.
So let's talk
about the monolith.
It used to be, and still is, a
Ruby-based API with JavaScript
front-end and native apps
communicating with the API.
And surrounding
that API were lots
of different object stores,
databases, caches, proxies, et
cetera.
But it all revolves
around that single API,
and thus we're dependent
on that API always working.
We did manual deployments
using Capistrano.
We ran our application
on three machines.
They were running here in
a data center in Amsterdam.
And we had an
operations engineer
responsible for the production
environment of our product.
So there are obviously
some pain points
here that we wanted to solve.
For example, these three.
Manual deployments,
we can all agree--
takes a lot of time, and it
includes a higher potential
of human error.
So you need to get
away with that.
Running a single application
on a few machines
also means that you're not
using the full utilization
of those machines, thus
increasing the cost of running
your application.
And having development
of production
be managed by different
teams automatically means
that there is less
accountability.
Different people are
responsible for different parts,
different lifecycle stages
of your application.
And that can complicate
things a lot.
But the other two could also
be scratched off this list.
Because, like I said before,
using a single API which
has to be performant, and
easy, et cetera, is difficult.
There is not one true language
which can handle this all,
or one true environment
which can handle this all.
So we moved to microservices.
We've been doing this
for some time now.
And actually, what we noticed
is that the technology
problems aren't the problems
that you should worry about.
You have a lot of smart
engineers at your company.
They know how to solve this.
But besides that,
there are a lot
of smart people working
at Google, at Red hat,
at other companies.
They put tons of hours--
again, if you saw early in
the Keynote, put tons of hours
in working on these
projects like Kubernetes
to help you solve
those problems.
In fact, it's about conceptual
problems and processes
that intertwine with your
stack, your application.
That's something outside
people can't work on,
because it's your team
who has to work on that.
And that's what made
this interesting.
For example, the
biggest challenge we saw
is that defining what
part of your monolith
you're going to split off
into microservices is key.
You don't just take
a part like, this
looks like a good
block of content
that we can take and
put into a microservice.
You have to think about
the domain boundaries.
If you don't do
that, you'll actually
end up right back where
you started, but worse.
You'll have a monolith
split between microservices
which has to communicate
over the networking layer
to call different functions
in different microservices.
And we all know adding a
network layer increases the risk
of hard-to-debug errors.
So always go the
extra mile, not only
to make sure that you
understand the different domains
of your product,
but also to prevent
too much chatter
and too much tight
coupling between your services.
And this is key to having
a successful microservice
oriented architecture.
If you don't, like I said,
you will probably end up back
where you were in the beginning.
And Martin Fowler-- he was
a famous software architect
and author.
He works at ThoughtWorks
and he's also
one of the original authors
of the "Manifesto for Agile
Software Development."
I think he said it best.
He said, "Almost
all the cases where
I've heard of a
system that was built
as a microservice
system from scratch,
it has ended up in
serious trouble."
You need to have production
experience with your domains
in order to understand where it
makes sense to split them off
and where it doesn't.
Or taken another way,
he said, "Almost all
the successful
microservice stories
have started with a
monolith that got too big
and was broken up."
So this is very important.
So how does Kubernetes
fit into this picture?
Like I said before,
once you figure out
how you want to split
up your microservices,
the technology isn't
really the problem.
Kubernetes will help
you with that part.
Of course, it takes time.
Of course, there are challenges
you have to overcome.
But as far as we've seen,
you can overcome them,
and there is a big
community around you
to help you with that.
I think Kubernetes
turned out to be
much more than a simple
container schedule for us.
It was a way to
empower our employees
to experiment and self-manage.
We actually saw an increase in
teams and individuals deploying
simple applications
that they built,
either at the end of the day,
or during a day where there
was nothing else
they were working on,
or they a built some cool
project on the weekends.
These things can then easily be
deployed to your entire company
and then be used by people.
And that fosters innovation
and increasing speed
of your deployment cycles.
So these are some numbers
about our Kubernetes
cluster [INAUDIBLE].
We host our Kubernetes cluster
on GCE, Google Container
Engine.
We have eight nodes, of which
six are preemptable VMs.
And on those are
running 575 pods.
134 services.
And what's interesting about
this is that because we
use preemptable VMs--
there will be a talk
about this later today,
I think, about what
those are, in case
you don't know what they are.
But to quickly explain, a
preemptable VM allows you to--
it gives you a machine
which can, at any time,
be taken back by Google because
they need the resources.
But you get a steep
discount on these machines.
And because we're
running on Kubernetes,
and we are scaling up, and
we have multiple replicates
per service running, it doesn't
matter if a machine drops out.
Because the application
will stay up.
And what it does bring
us is a reduced cost.
And it brings us automated chaos
monkey-like infrastructure,
where machines will
fill all the time,
and then our engineers
need to be wary of that
and need to design
their applications to be
highly available.
So what does Kubernetes
mean for us in practice?
All the services are highly
available, like I said.
Even the most simple ones we
replicate at least three times,
just because we
want to make sure
that it's always
running, even if it's
an internal application.
And combined with microservices
with clearly defined domain
boundaries, like I
told about earlier,
it means we haven't
had a complete failure
of our application within at
least the last year or maybe
more.
Things do still
break, of course.
We're only human.
But the impact of
something breaking
isn't as big as Blendle is down.
It might be as big as
search isn't working.
Or the email is delayed,
and is not on time
to our customers, which is
bad, and we to fix that.
But people can still
use our product.
And on top of that, we went from
a couple of manual deployments
every week to sometimes
50 releases per day.
All our applications
are automatically
tested and
automatically deployed.
So let's take a quick look
at some real-world use cases.
For example, Blendle
Button, which
is a product that we
built where, in this case,
the folks can put
it on their website,
and people can buy the article
for a few cents with the wallet
they have at Blendle.
And we ship that in
a couple of months,
and we actually-- this
was our first microservice
that we built on
top of Kubernetes.
I think Kubernetes was
still version 0.9 back then,
so I would say don't
try this at home,
but eventually, things work out.
Also, Goals is an
interesting use case,
because a product manager, lead
product manager at our company,
wanted a tool that could
help us focus on our OKRs
and on personal goal-setting
that all engineers at Blendle
have.
He built a quick tool, used
Ruby on Rails, real simple.
Bootstrap for the front-end.
And he deployed
it on our cluster,
and everyone is using it
at our company right now.
So it's really awesome.
Something like this, where
two engineers at Blendle
build a spreadsheet which
automatically queries
the Kubernetes API in which
every team who deploys
an application, Kubernetes
adds a little bit of metadata
to the deployment where
people can find support
for this application.
So adding a name, multiple
names, adding in git-repo,
adding in email address,
stuff like that.
And then it's automatically
consolidated into a spreadsheet
for people to find out, for
example, the support team,
like who can I ask
about this problem?
So these are some examples.
Continuous deployment
is another big one.
We are actually running our own
continuous deployment pipeline
on top of Kubernetes.
So we deploy to Kubernetes
from a continuous deployment
pipeline which is
run on Kubernetes,
and it auto-scales for
whatever requirements
we have at that moment.
So if a lot of teams are
deploying at that time,
it just auto-scales it.
It adds more nodes,
it adds more pods,
and it's able to
deploy in a couple
seconds, or for bigger projects,
in a couple of minutes.
To recap, I think
starting with a monolith,
or at least having a
clear understanding
on why you need
microservices, is key.
If you use Kubernetes,
and in our example,
Google Container Engine, the
problem becomes less technical.
You need to focus on the
operational and conceptual
parts of these problems.
Teams become self-managed.
They can release better,
they can release more.
You empower your teams.
And as for us, you can
release a new service
in less than an hour.
If someone has an ID,
they built something,
we have a continuous
deployment pipeline.
They can ship it.
Thanks everyone for
your time, and I'd
like to give it back to Matt.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT FEIGAL: Thank
you very much, sir.
Hey, everyone!
Thanks for letting
me back on stage.
I do need to keep moving
fast, but I'll also
try to keep up a little
energy through this next part
of the technical story.
What is it about Kubernetes
that makes it such a great place
to run many, many microservices
in a resilient way
and empower your
teams like this?
Kubernetes has many
powerful cases and features.
They've been built over
the last 2 and 1/2 years
by the open source community and
Google and other contributing
partners working together.
Companies like yours,
companies like Blendle.
We launched it to the
open source community
with the intention of
growing these use cases,
because we know how
Google used these things.
We needed to know how
you needed to use them.
And the community has
built up these use cases.
Underneath all of these
tools, all of these things
that you wish you could do
with your microservices,
I would say it boils down to
four key technical concepts.
If you understand those
four key technical concepts,
you understand everything
that's built on top of them
in terms of how the
system works and why
it's good for microservices.
So I'm going to explain
pods, replica sets, services,
and then labels, which is
how they all find and talk
to each other, through the eye
of a microservice development
team.
Pods are the smallest
deployable unit.
Why not a container?
Well, we know from our
experience at Google--
hard-won experience--
that sometimes you
want to deploy multiple
containers together.
They will live and die together.
They share the same
cozy network space.
They'll always deploy
together on the same node.
You don't tell Kubernetes
to deploy a container.
You tell it to deploy a pod.
Now, often, a pod will
be just one container.
Your front-end team
builds a Node.js thing.
It doesn't need anything else.
They put it in--
they compile it in Docker,
ship it to the registry.
You establish your template,
that this is my pod.
That'll get deployed
on machines.
Sometimes, it's not even
something you've built.
You're using a
third-party software
like Elasticsearch for
your product search.
Kubernetes has tools in there,
like to attach a volume to it.
And the template says, get
this Elasticsearch instance,
get this volume that it's going
to need, put five copies of it
in different nodes, you're
going to take care of it.
It could also be
other languages.
So say you're
streaming team says,
for high-performance
stuff, we need Go.
We also see something
introduced here now,
a second container
in the same pod.
We have this-- I would call
it a sidecar container.
You could call it a helper
container, or maybe,
in old-fashioned language,
you might call it
cross-cutting concerns.
Say you had something--
you said, well,
we need the SSL offloading
to happen in a certain way.
Let's have a team build
a container around that.
We put it in the same pod.
Our Go team doesn't
need to know it happens.
Our Go team just gets
the message passed in.
Without this, the Go
team would have to think,
all right, now,
in my application,
I have to build this SSL
piece into my application.
Now, it doesn't care.
It just gets the information
straight from the other pod.
So these sidecar
containers really
help you separate out these
cross-cutting concerns
so you have less dependencies,
and your developers
focus on just the
piece they want.
And then it gets much
more complicated.
You've got your Java team
with 10 years of experience,
and they might also
have a logging agent
that they use that
you want to separate
from out of their code.
Or even, for instance, you can
put .NET Core in a container
now, which means you can
run it on Kubernetes.
I've got a customer
sitting right there that
does that in production.
World Press Photos was on
stage a few minutes ago.
They do this in production.
So it's a new world that
we can do this stuff now.
So on the microservices side,
let's take the big red button
that Blendle wants to deploy.
What does that look like
in Kubernetes world?
The first thing we need to
know-- you understand pods, so
the next thing to understand
is the replica set.
This is essentially
just a control loop.
You declare the state
you want it to be in.
It's responsible for
pulling that pod you want,
throwing on it
all of the nodes--
doesn't matter which ones--
making sure that
they're running.
So it's going to do
these health check loops.
If a pod dies, which is going
to happen-- things go wrong.
You have an out-of-memory
error, a node crashes.
Nobody gets alerted,
nobody gets woken up
in the middle of the night.
The replica set just
notices that and says,
oh, let me start another one
somewhere else and fixes it.
It's basically like the
"Star Trek" "make it so."
So the replica set will
create the state you want
and then keep the state
you want as things go wrong
in your environment
and things change.
The other side of that
microservice angle
is the service.
People need to reach it.
Your outside audience
needs to reach it,
or you're doing some
internal services.
A service is a logical
grouping of pods
that all have the same function
based on this label selector.
So it's using this label,
looking for front-end.
[GASPS] Oh, there's
a bug on my slide.
It's looking for back-end, but
it's finding the front-end one.
So that's a user bug, not the--
Incoming requests are going
to be load-balanced across all
of the pods that match.
This means your service
gets a stable virtual IP,
its own port, and
even its own DNS
name, which you can use
for service discovery
and routing inside.
So all of that is handled
for you by Kubernetes.
You put these two
things together,
you have your microservice.
The replica set and
the service combine
to make your microservice.
The replica set's taking
care of the resilience.
The service is handling the
service discovery and routing.
And now, bam, you've got people
hitting your big red button.
People deploy it on their sites,
traffic's going to hit it.
It's always going to be here.
Kubernetes is going to
take care of that for you.
Your application
developers didn't need
to think about all this stuff.
But that's not the end of it.
We don't just create.
We need to change.
Big red button goes live,
it needs a lot of traffic.
How do we scale it up as
we add more publishers?
Well, this still leverages
the same core concepts.
We just tell the replica set,
give me four instead of three,
or 10 instead of three.
And the replica set makes
it so-- bam, bam, bam.
Now you've got 10 instances,
and the service just
keeps finding them.
Oh, I've got to fix that
back-end front-end thing.
Sorry.
But we can't always predict what
our scaling needs are, right?
Blendle's selling this.
They onboard a new publisher
with millions of visitors.
They don't know how fast
it's going to take off.
Or maybe they get
a sudden burst.
Maybe an existing publisher
with multiple properties
has tested it out on
here, and then one day
says, great, let's launch it
on all of "New York Times."
And just puts it-- boom.
So bam, 10 times the visitors
that they didn't even
tell you about, right?
Because you're
selling it to them
as a software as a service.
You're saying, we're going
to manage this for you,
and you just do
whatever you want.
And so they do.
They surprise you.
Oh, yeah-- bam.
Oh, we didn't tell you
we were going to launch
to 10 million new visitors?
Sorry.
You want it to be able to scale.
This also uses these
same core concepts.
Every pod is
reporting its metrics
to a central metric
system in Kubernetes.
Internally, it's Heapster.
And you define the
auto-scaling rule
in Kubernetes for
your application.
Again, your
application developers
don't know about this.
They don't care.
Setting a target-- a
CPU is a common target.
There's other ones
that you can use.
Say if it's above 50% average,
give me more pods until
it's-- and just run that.
And then when it drops
below, mark this pod
that it doesn't get
any new traffic.
When it's done serving traffic,
kill it, save resources.
I want to use those
for other things.
So this is all built on
top of these core concepts
that we talked
about in Kubernetes.
Other things you
want to do with this
microservice-- you need
to do canary deployments.
Or you want to deploy
a new, big, red button.
You want to deploy
the big blue button,
or the big green button,
or the round, red button.
Or you just want it
to behave differently.
Probably user interface
you can handle.
There's a lot of
strategies for this.
Rolling upgrades,
blue-green deployments.
Even just A/B testing.
You want to keep them
both alive for a while.
They all use essentially
the same technique
built on these core concepts.
You have your replica
set with your service.
Your replica set says,
this is all version 1.
You add a new replica set with
version 2, but the same label.
The service just finds it
and groups it in together,
so you're actually
running these in parallel.
And you can do a rolling upgrade
this way, where you add one
and remove one.
It's an automatic
tooling for that.
Or you can keep them both
alive and measure for a week.
There's a lot of
different ways to--
that's how you do it.
You've just, for free--
well, not for free.
For a tiny bit of attention
from your engineering
or your planning
team, you have all
of these things in Kubernetes.
Breaking it down, what does
your single microservice
look like in the
Kubernetes cluster?
The replica set
is where you just
specify how many you
want of how many copies
of your application.
The replica set reaches
out to your registry,
where all your compiled
packaged containers
are, says, I need
these four containers,
or whatever you've defined.
And it finds home for
them on the nodes--
you don't care which
nodes they land on--
and puts them out there.
You define your
service endpoint.
And now your routing traffic,
your microservice is live.
A couple of little
things-- in fact,
we've even boiled it down to
one command called deployments.
But you can still do it
the old-fashioned way
with these individual
pieces, if you like.
That's it.
Guy was taking a picture.
That's done, OK.
So that's what your single
microservice looks like.
But you're a big company.
You're running 134
microservices together.
You don't just have a
single microservice.
Your team might think
about one, but everybody's
got to think about it.
It's going to look
more like this.
You're still scheduling
it across all those nodes.
You've defined your microservice
by replica set and front-end.
And it could be all this stuff.
Your Go team is happy,
your Node.js team is happy.
You're not arguing
about dependencies
and having religious wars
about what language to use.
And you can run all
these things together.
There's another
thing you probably
want to do as you're
doing long-term lifecycle
of these microservices.
There's that logging
agent as an example.
That's a cross-cutting concern.
We got it out of our code.
Our developers don't
think about it anymore.
They just write to
log, or whatever.
And the logging agent picks
it up from all of them
and sends it to our
shared repository.
Blendle did this a
couple weeks ago.
They've got a separate team
running this logging agent.
Oh, it's time to make a change.
We need to update that.
Could be a small change,
could be a big one.
In the old world, you've got
to go to all of those 60 teams
and ask them, it's time to
update your logging agent.
Please update this library in
Java, please update this thing.
And if you're lucky,
20 of the teams
have time on their backlog to do
it this week, And you get done.
And 20 of the teams
are in high-priority,
we're in crunch mode,
we're launching something.
We'll get to it next quarter.
And 20 of the teams
say, screw you guys.
We like our own logging tools.
We're not going to change.
And so you end up with
this really-- consistency
across this environment of these
types of things becomes hard.
So you just went
to microservices
like oh, yeah, this
is going be great.
And now suddenly, you have
a consistency problem.
So in the Kubernetes
landscape, how
this supports your
microservices is they just
say, well, look, the team
responsible for that logging
agent just says,
we're going to update
that container in our registry.
We are going to define new pod
templates for every team that
has the new logging agent.
And just easily,
with just a couple
of little automation
like that, they've
swiped out the old logging
agent and replaced it
with their new logging agent.
And they didn't have
to take up the head
cycles, the time of any of those
application developer teams.
Those teams could focus on
what they're supposed to do--
the next product,
the next feature.
So that is, I think,
the story of why
Kubernetes is a great place for
your resilient microservices.
New stuff coming out--
because we're short on time,
we won't talk so much about it.
I'll give a link to it.
The new stuff coming out
is Istio, a service mesh.
What's a service mesh?
Imagine you had to build
HTTP retries and rate
limiting encryption,
injecting SSL certificates.
You're a big enterprise.
You're a bank or something.
You need consistency
across all of these things.
You can't just rely on
these cowboy developers.
And anyway, you don't want
those application developers
to be thinking about that.
You want them just
to live there.
So you need this consistency
across your whole landscape.
In the same model that we had
with the logging containers,
you basically--
Istio solves this problem
in a consistent way
across your whole space by
injecting it into Kubernetes.
Istio will run anywhere.
It's a partnership of IBM
and Google teaming up.
Wow, it's the future.
And Lyft-- this
crazy taxi startup,
who supplied this great
Level 7 load balancer.
So they teamed up--
17 years of experience
running services.
Input from hundreds of
enterprises from Google and IBM
and this amazing L7
load balancer from Lyft
provide this environment.
Essentially, you will be
able to run it anywhere.
They've launched it in
open-source method, same way
that we have from Kubernetes
2 and 1/2, 3 years ago.
I can see the same
momentum building up.
So today, it's for the
bleeding-edge people.
Six months from
now, you're going
to want to run it in
your own data center.
It's going to be amazing.
If you want to get started,
I found a really nice little
Getting Started around
Istio.io/docs/tasks.
So you like this
idea in general.
You want to get started on it.
This is where I think you start.
g.co/codelab/cloud has some
really nice Container Engine
deployments.
In two hours, you'll deploy
your own test microservice.
Hell, two hours later, you can
deploy your own microservice
using the same techniques.
We've also got Code Lab
booths out there to the back.
Say you're a .NET
developer, and you say,
I want to try this magic.
There's a whole series taking a
.NET Core from deploy, simply,
to containerizing it to
putting it into Kubernetes.
There's the test thing.
Also, Outback training--
if your company says,
we want to do this,
but we need training,
a bunch of the partners
out there provide training.
Or if you say, we want to do
this, but we need a jump start,
we need someone to help us get
moving, there's also partners
out there that
are really, really
good at helping teach your teams
to do this so you can do it
yourselves.
And I guess that's it.
Exactly on time.
Or no, I'm 20 seconds over.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]